the people who
i've found that i worked with repeatedly
are people who they only want to see
everyone around them succeed
the only person you should try to beat
is the person you were yesterday yes
is that something yeah i believe that
wholeheartedly i think that there's this
i don't know i mean i don't know where
it comes from but there's a sense of
competition in in the arts
and
everybody is looking at their peers the
person next to them and they're trying
to make sure they're
one-upping that person and trying to be
better than that person
and
then they start following these weird
trends and you find everybody doing the
same thing and their only sense of
growth is that their sense of gross
growth is measured by
how far they've distanced themselves
from the next person
and for me that's just
that's not the case it's it's a it makes
it very tough to grow and i'm always
trying to learn and grow in everything i
do and the only way you can really
measure that growth is if you look at
the work that you've done before
and how much
more you've improved
how much closer are you to achieving
whatever it is you see in your head
because when i sit down and i write i've
seen the movie in my head and when i
step on the set i'm ready to bring
whatever's in my head
to the screen
and how
the way i gauge my own success and the
way i gauge my own growth is by how much
closer
have i gotten to that
with each project i feel like in the
beginning i was at
maybe i think one of the first films i
did i said i was probably got like five
percent of what was in my head on the
screen because it's all about learning
how to communicate and and work
effectively with everyone on the set you
know um
it's about the team where the teamwork
makes a dream work right and it's about
learning how to work with your team how
do you deliver the information that they
need in a way that they can understand
and execute
effectively
and
with each project i think
you're supposed to grow and get better
at that communication
and
you know you can view the work to see
your growth but if you're constantly
measuring yourself by what everybody
else is doing where is your real growth
true let me just play the devil's
advocate for a second though because
sometimes you can have a strong mindset
like that but then you get
individuals from the side and they want
to rope you into their competition
and it's up to you to say oh i don't
think i'm playing today
um but but we're human and we get you
know i mean look the movie eighth grade
for those of us who remember being a
female in eighth grade it reminds me a
lot of that you know and there's still
an aspect of that to adult life and
especially in entertainment and so how
do you handle when you can tell you're
being challenged and roped into some
kind of weird competitive thing and
you're saying no this is my path my lane
is here your lane is there
and i think fortunately i
i haven't been wrote in that i do know a
filmmaker who
i i think they're in competition with me
but i think that that's all in their
head because in order for it to be a
competition two people have to be
playing um but i don't bother to
participate because i know what it is
that i'm trying to accomplish i know
what my lane is and and the the kind of
projects that i'm looking to create and
how i'm looking to create them and
realistically
the only person in that lane is is me
and even if there was another person who
was doing this the same or something
similar i would give them whatever
knowledge i have to help them succeed at
whatever they're trying to accomplish
because that's the way we all win is if
we're all helping each other
i think that if you look at
let's just say the the top one percent
in hollywood right
they all
really know each other
in some form of fashion this guy knew
that guy who worked with this guy and
they came up and then this guy reached
back and helped this guy and then this
lady helped this guy and this guy help
this lady that's how it all went
everybody helped everybody get to where
they are
by not considering themselves
competition by only wanting to see
their peers succeed
i think that's the way it works so even
if i did realize that someone was trying
to to rope me into this this competition
i would just say
what do you need for me to help you that
that's the conversation i i'd rather
have how can i help you
how can i help you i want to help you
grow and help you succeed i want to help
you be the best you possible
so uh let's start working on that let's
have that conversation
you would he would really do that if you
even if you saw like their sort of
underhanded tactics you would really
want to help well i because i guess
their underhanded tactics what would
they be for me i don't know what they
would be for me because i don't report
to anyone i finance my own projects so
who how can they be underhanded what i
mean i guess if they were trying to
maybe
you know influence an actor to not take
the role or something like that and i
would just tell them ah that's not cool
that you did that but
i guess it serves some sort of purpose
for you you get some kind of
satisfaction out of it but whatever
because ultimately it's not going to
change the fact that i'm still going to
create this project
it's it's not going to really change
that fact
and did you notice that more when you
came here to southern california or or
it was the same in georgia
people are people everywhere yeah i
think people are people everywhere i
think that
here it's it's it's
there's a bit more
you know fuel pushed into the fire
because the stakes are so high
and the opportunities are so small i
think that you know that puts a little
bit more fuel in the fire
but
in saying that the people who
i found that i worked with repeatedly
are people who they only want to see
everyone around them succeed
they're constantly trying to find
opportunities to to bring in more people
that would find some sort of benefit
from whatever they're doing
and
that's what's made me keep working with
them and i see them being successful as
well i see them being successful now
and it's it's all because they'd much
rather focus on
reaching back and being of use
than
trying to compete
just be of use
i told you that was one of the things i
learned from john singleton be of use be
helpful
never ruin a good day
by thinking about a bad yesterday yeah
that's a good one yeah
leave leave that stuff in the past
whatever it is leave it in the past it's
not it's not helpful
it's not helpful um i found a lot of
people who sit back and still talk about
that film they made that one time that
many years ago and this person
ticked them off and it was this person's
fault and it was that and it was this
and it was
leave that stuff alone leave it in the
past learn your lessons and take those
lessons moving forward and apply them to
whatever you're trying to create today
if you keep focusing on what happened
yesterday you have no appreciation for
what's happening to you right now in the
present and you definitely can't really
plan for the future because you're too
busy thinking about what happened
yesterday yesterday is gone
it's gone
so just just leave the problems of
yesterday back there and take the
lessons you learned with you
like that one story of the guy that
drives around with no rear view mirror
they say how come you don't have a rear
view mirror and he says i don't need to
see where i've been
that's a great one that's a great one
i'm not sure if it's a real story but
i've heard other people say it so yeah
um
do you think we can really live without
pain and regret do i think it's possible
to live without pain and regret
i definitely think so
i definitely think so i think that um
[Music]
the
pain is just your way of uh well in in
some instances i can't speak to all
kinds of pain because some pain comes
from the grief of losing someone or you
know so so i can't speak to that type of
pain but i can take to talk to the pain
of any regret of making poor decisions
and i think that ultimately
that kind that type of pain and that
type of regret
is you understanding you've done
something
you've done something
wrong whether it be just incorrect or
something actually wrong
and you need to actually fix that and
learn your lesson from that move forward
and take that lesson with you if you are
constantly growing from the things that
are happening to you in life if you're
constantly taking those lessons and
moving forward to make sure they don't
happen again i do think you can live
without that pain and that regret that
type of pain and that type of regret
yeah certainly
justin can you explain to us why having
a plan b
i believe used to be very important to
you and then it changed
oh yeah that's easy if you have a plan b
you'll most often use a plan b
you'll never go as hard after plan a if
you think you have something to fall
back on
throughout my entire life everything
i've done has been
somewhat involved in the arts i i you
know i told you before i drew comics i
wrote stories short stories
i was in the band i did you know i was
in the in the chorus as well i'm not a
good singer though i was
but the thing about it is it's always
been in the arts and
the arts have always been something i
pursued but i've always been told always
have a plan b always have a plan b
always have a plan b so even going to
college i had a plan b i knew that i
wanted to be in the arts i knew that i
wanted to write
but
i all i felt back on on
on rotc because i'd always been in rocc
even in high school so i fell back on
that and i had something to work with if
nothing else worked i could you know
take up something in the military but
ultimately
as i moved further and further
throughout this career and i grew more
and more inside of the career
in this industry i started to realize i
never went as hard after
my plan a because i was always focusing
on keeping my plan b healthy
and all that energy that i was putting
into plan b
and constantly thinking of
if if this doesn't work i can escape
here and if this doesn't work i can
escape here because i spent so much time
doing that i was taking away a lot of
energy from plan a where if i had
invested all of that and went full bore
into that
you i would have been
much more successful quicker
i think that i do believe you know
opportunity means preparation and maybe
it was the opportunities were coming
along much later but i think i would
have created all new opportunities had i
focused really hard uh or and just more
on plan a i think that warren buffett
said you know you only have to be right
51 of the time that's it you only have
to be right 51 of the time to be
successful and if you were throwing
everything you had at plan a
the chances of your success improve
greatly
you know they just do
i don't know too much about rotc but
how much of that training or being
around like minds helped you sort of be
resilient and maybe take things less
personal than others might take um
well i i think that more than anything
it teaches you accountability and
responsibility and when you hold
yourself accountable for something it
doesn't really matter other people's
critique of whatever you do is it's
either constructive or not and if it's
not you just toss it away because you
yourself are holding yourself
accountable to a higher standard than
than most other people would hold you to
anyway
um
so i that's more than anything else is
what i took away from rotc just that
accountability and and the
responsibility
sure so showing up
not only showing up but but showing up
and being prepared more prepared than
everybody else is know know as much as
you possibly can about everything that's
going on and try to make try to apply
that to whatever your specific task is
you know
you